nos dicen que es benito tiene un cuarto
de kilogramo de cereal quiere
compartirlo por igual entre él y su
hermano cuánto serial obtendrá cada uno
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien ahora trabajaremos juntos en
esto benito comienza con un cuarto de
kilogramo de cereal entonces cómo
podemos representar un cuarto bueno si
esto es un kilogramo entero imaginemos
que este rectángulo es un kilogramo
completo podría dividirlo en cuatro
secciones iguales entonces veamos esto
sería aproximadamente dos secciones
iguales y luego si dividimos cada una de
ellas en dos ahora tendremos cuatro
secciones iguales benito comienza con un
cuarto de kilogramo trataré de dibujarlo
un poco más parejo benito comienza con
un cuarto de kilogramo así que digamos
que este es el cuarto de kilogramo con
el que comienza está comenzando con un
cuarto de kilogramo y quiere compartirlo
equitativamente entre él y su hermano
aquí dice que él quiere compartirlo
equitativamente entre dos personas lo
que queremos hacer es comenzar con la
cantidad total de cereal y luego
dividirla en dos partes
cuando nos preguntan cuánto serial
obtendría cada uno realmente estamos
tratando de calcular a que es igual este
cuarto dividido entre 2 entonces aquí es
igual esto bueno y si tomáramos todas
estas cuatro secciones iguales y las
dividiéramos entre 2 dividimos este
entre 2 dividimos este otro entre 2 lo
dividimos entre dos y luego dividimos
este entre 2 y ahora a que son iguales
cada una de estas secciones bueno cada
una ahora es un octavo esto es un octavo
justo allí el entero lo dividimos en
ocho secciones iguales y podemos ver que
cuando comenzamos con este cuarto y lo
dividimos en dos secciones iguales esta
es una sección y esta es otra sección
igual cada una de estas es igual a un
octavo entonces un cuarto dividido entre
dos es igual a un octavo hagamos otro
ejemplo nos dicen mario está llenando
contenedores de arroz cada recipiente
puede contener hasta un cuarto de
kilogramo de arroz si mario tiene tres
kilogramos de arroz
los recipientes puede llenar como
siempre pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo muy bien entonces
pensemos en lo que está pasando
comenzamos con una cantidad total tres
kilogramos de arroz y estamos tratando
de dividirlo en secciones iguales en
este caso estamos tratando de dividirlo
en secciones iguales de un cuarto de
kilogramo así que estamos tratando de
averiguar a que es igual tres dividido
entre un cuarto ahora para imaginar esto
pensemos en tres enteros estos serían
tres kilogramos enteros esto es un
entero estos son dos enteros estoy
tratando de hacerlas todas iguales pero
estoy dibujando a mano por lo que no es
tan exacto como me gustaría entonces
estos son tres kilogramos enteros aquí y
él quiere dividirlo en secciones de un
cuarto por lo que si lo divide en
cuartos cuántos cuartos va a tener bueno
hagámoslo
si lo dividiéramos en mitades se vería
así dividimos estos tres enteros en
mitades luego si queremos dividirlos en
cuartos quedaría así estoy tratando de
hacer secciones iguales
secciones exactamente iguales entonces
ahí lo tenemos a partir de tres enteros
los dividimos en cuartos cuántos cuartos
hay bueno hay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 y
12 cuartos por lo que 3 dividido entre
un cuarto es igual a 12 y los invito a
que piense en el por qué tenemos este
resultado si tomamos un número entero
como 3 y lo dividimos entre un cuarto
obtendremos un valor más grande que 3 y
estamos obteniendo un valor que es 4 por
3 piensen porque ese es el caso